So let's talk about new MRI, which is an incredible company,
uh, system idea, I think, but good place to start.
What is new Mariah and how does it work?
So numerous, the first hedge fund that gives away all of its data.
So this is like probably the last thing a hedge fund would do, right?
Why would we give away a data it's like giving away your edge? Um,
but the reason we do it is because we're looking for people to model our
data and the way we do it is by Optus skating the data.
So when you get, when you look at numerous data that you can download for free,
it just looks like,
like a million rows and numbers between zero and one.
And you have no idea what the columns mean,
but you do know that if you're good at machine learning or have done
regressions before, you know that I can still find patents in this data,
even though I don't know, I don't know what the features mean.
And, and the data itself is a time series data.
And even though it's office created anonymized,
what is the source data like, approximately what are we talking about?
So we are buying data from lots of different data vendors, um,
and they would also never want us to share that data. Um,
so we have strict contracts with them. So we only, we only can, but it,
but that's the kind of data you could never buy yourself unless you had maybe a
million dollars a year of budget to buy data.
So what's happened with the hedge fund industry is you have a lot of talented
people who used to be able to trade
and still can trade, but now they have such a data disadvantage.
It would never make sense for them to, um, to, to, to trade themselves.
But Numerai by giving away this obfuscated data, we can give them a really,
really high quality dataset that's that would otherwise be very expensive and
they can use whatever new machine learning technique they want, uh,
to find patterns in that data that we can use in our hedge fund.
And so how much variety is there? The underlying data we're talking about of,
I apologize if I'm using the wrong terms,
but there's one is just like the stock price,
the other there's like options and all that kind of stuff. Like the,
what are they called? Order books or whatever the, like I is,
is there maybe other totally unrelated to directly to the stock
market data? Like, like natural language as well, all that kind of stuff.
Yeah. We were really focused on, um,
stock data that's specific to stocks. So, um,
things like you can have like a P every stock has like a PE ratio for some
stocks. It's not as meaningful, but every stock has that.
Every stock has one year momentum, how much they went up in the last year.
Um, but those are very common factors,
but we try to get lots and lots of those factors that we have for many,
many years, like 15, 20 years history. Um, and,
and then the setup of the problem is commonly seen in quantum code.
Like cross-sectional global equity. You're not really trying to say, I want, I,
I believe the stock will go up. You're trying to say, um,
the like relative position of this stock in feature space, uh,
makes it not a bad buy in, uh, in a portfolio.
So it captures some period of time. And you're trying to find the patterns,
the dynamics captured by the data of that period of time in order to make
short-term predictions about what's going to happen.
Yeah. So our predictions also, not that short, we're not really, um,
caring about things like order books and tick data, uh,
not high-frequency at all. We actually holding things for quite a bit longer.
Uh, so prediction time horizon is about one month.
We ended up holding stocks for maybe like three or four months.
So I kind of believe that's a little bit more like investing than, um,
than kind of plumbing, like to go long,
a stock that's mispriced on one exchange and short on another exchange.
That's just arbitrage. But what we're trying to do is really no, no,
no. Something more about the longer-term future.
The stock. Yeah.
So from the patterns from these like periods of a time series, did it,
you're trying to understand something fundamental about the stock,
not like about deep value,
about like is big in the context of the market is under priced over priced,
all that kind of stuff. So like, this is about investing.
It's not about just like you said, high frequency trading,
which I think is a fascinating open question for machine learning perspective,
but just to sort of build on that.
So you have anonymized the data and now you're giving away the data.
And then now anyone can try to,
uh, build algorithms that make investing decisions on top of that data or
predictions and the top of that data. Exactly. And so that that's, um,
what is it, so what does that look like? What's the goal that,
what are the underlying principles of that?
So the first thing is, you know, we could obviously model that data in house,
right? We can make an extra boost model on the data. Um,
and that would be quite good too. But what we're trying to do is by,
by, uh, opening it up and letting anybody participate, uh,
we can do quite a lot better than if we modeled it ourselves
and a lot better on the stock market.
It doesn't need to be very much like it really matters the difference between if
you can make 10 and 12% in equity market neutral hedge fund, because the whole,
usually you're try, you're charging 2% fees.
So if you can do 2% better, that's like all your fees it's worth it.
So we're trying to make sure that we always have best possible model as new
machine learning libraries come out, new new techniques come out,
they get automatically synthesized.
Like if there's a great paper on supervised learning,
someone on Numerai will figure out how to use it on numerous data.
Is there an ensemble of, uh,
models going on or is it always,
or is it more towards kind of like one or two or three,
like best performing models?
So the way we decide on how to weight,
all of the predictions together is, um,
by how much the users are staking on them,
how much of the cryptocurrency that they're putting behind their models.
So they're saying, I believe in my model,
tra you can trust me because I'm going to put skin in the game. Um,
and so we can take the stake weighted predictions from all our users,
add those together, average those together.
And that's a much better model than any one model in the, in the sun,
because ensembling a lot of models together is kind of the key thing you need to
do in investing to.
Yeah. So you're putting, there's a kind of duality from the user,
from the perspective of machine learning engineer,
what you're is both a competition, just a really interesting,
difficult machine learning problem. And it's, uh,
a way to, to invest algorithmically. So like you're, and,
but the,
the way to invest algorithmically also is a way to put skin in the
game that communicates to you that your, uh, the,
the quality of the algorithm, and also forces you to really, uh,
be serious about the models that you build. So it's like,
everything just works nicely together. Like, um,
I guess one way to say that as the interests are aligned. Okay.
So, uh, it's just like poker as not,
not fun when it's like for very low stakes, the higher the stakes,
the more the dynamics of the system starts playing out correctly. Uh,
like as a small side note,
is there something you can say about which kind looking at the
big, broad view of machine learning today, or AI,
what kind of algorithms seem to do good in these kinds of
competitions at this time? Is there some universal thing you can say,
like neural networks suck a recurring y'all know our SOC transformers suck or
they're awesome.
Like old school sort of more basic kind of classifiers are better. All the Xer.
Is there some kind of conclusion so far that you can say, okay.
There definitely is something pretty nice about tree models, uh, like,
like XG boost, um, and, uh,
they just seem to work pretty nicely on this type of data. Uh,
so out of the box,
if you're trying to come hundredth in the competition in the tournament,
maybe you would try and use that. Um, but what's,
what's particularly interesting about the, the problem that, um,
not many people understand if you're familiar with machine learning, um,
this typically will surprise you when you model all data. So, um,
one of the things that, uh,
you look at in finance is you don't want to be too exposed to any one risk.
Like even if the best sector in
the world to invest in over the last 10 years was tech, you would not,
does not mean you should put all your money into tech, right? So the,
if you train the model, it would say put all your money in tech. Super good.
But, um,
what you want to do is actually be very careful of how much of this exposure you
have to certain features. So on numerate,
what a lot of people figure out is actually,
if you train a model on this kind of data,
you want to somehow neutralize or minimize your exposure to these certain
features, which is unusual because if, if you did train, um,
a stoplight or stop street, uh, detection, uh, on computer vision,
uh, the, your, your favorite feature, let's say you could,
and you have an auto encoder and it's figuring out, okay,
it's gotta be red and it's gotta be white. That's the last thing you want to be.
You want to reduce your exposure to why would you reduce the exposure to the
thing that's helping you, your model the most.
And that's actually this counter-intuitive thing you have to do with machine
learning on financial data.
So reducing it's reducing your exposure would help you generalize the things
that are.
So basically financial data has a large amount of
patterns that appeared in the past,
and also a large amount of patterns that have not appeared in the past.
And so like, in that sense, you have to reduce the exposure to red lights, uh,
to, to the color red. That's interesting,
but how much of this is art and how much of it is science from your perspective
so far in terms of,
as you start to climb from the hundredth position to the 95th in the
competition?
Yeah. Well,
if you do make yourself super exposed to a one or
two features,
you can have a lot of volatility when you're playing new MRI.
You could maybe very rapidly rise to be high if you were
getting lucky. Yes. And that's a bit like the stock market. Sure.
Take on massive risk exposure,
put all your money into one stock and you might make a hundred percent,
but, um, it doesn't in the long run workout very well. And so,
um, the best users are,
are trying to stay high for as long as possible on
not, not necessarily try to be thirst for a little bit.